leute herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ich sitz hier gemeinsam mit sandy
wir haben was ganz besonderes
vorbestellen zufällig essen und du
machst gerade eigentlich eine sache
ursache fuhr aber für den lieben markt
setze natürlich ein tag aus und kann
eigentlich immer war es ja ich bin sehr
gespannt wie ihr hört übernahmen wieder
gebohrt die handelsdaten ich auf eine
mittagspause nennt der mittagspause
durch waren okay kommt dass uns schnell
in die liga abgeben
nein das hängt ja wieder an jetzt kraft
da das zeug und als allererstes lasst
mir bezahlt leben in welcher kategorie
wir stellen also du kannst einen sack
mit einer zahl zwischen 1 569 okay sagt
zahl zwischen 1 und 1 69 beziehungen
sagt uns angezahlt zwischen 1 und 69
sag mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 69 von
unten 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ich kann zwar nicht 61 sowie maxi kann
niebel ich liebe so stehe ich auf 34
durch die rechte wort wir entscheiden
auch zufällig was es kann auch sein dass
wir zum beispiel hinten fluggästen
gekommen
horas 2134 sagt uns eine zeit zwischen 1
und 34
emma heming 30 32 scheiß heißt der
letzte der zweitletzte max geben das ist
ja aber unten sind doch die schlechte
eine die haben keine lieferung achten
können die können wir gar nicht nur
sondern müssen wir leider noch mal her
übrigens falls ein bisschen komisch
spreche ich habe heute gebohrt programm
beim zahnarzt und die betäubung hört
gerade langsam auf aber es wird sagt mir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 31
mittendrin 78 19
sushi okay ich hab so bockhop so
schwierig sagt nie eine zahl zwischen 1
und 12 2 diese strippen das liest dann
denkt man kriegt immer versuche es gibt
nur eine suppe das heißt sie müssen wir
jetzt schon mal mit
so wird ist aber ganz lecker mehr kommt
dann mache ich als nächstes sagt mir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 12 6 inside out
sagt mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 14
bestimmte kleine miniatur mit reispapier
frischkäse laporta machst du dir was
sagte mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 14
patchwork aber egal martina die kleine
wo die zwei indirekt das ist aber karl
marx naja das ist echt was haben wir da
special rohre olemotz firmenfeier bitte
bitte 2 das war die geilste die wiederum
gesehen haben bitburg geräte sei wenn
ich jetzt nicht sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 3
mein gott wie geil geil du kriegst auf
jeden fall auch davon ab kommt redet ihr
noch aus sagten eine zeit zwischen 15
altern ist ich bin stolz auf unser rat
und bisher diesen rang hinter euch
danach ist sehr geil dann muss auch mit
zwei offen sagt mir eine zeit zwischen
einzelnen 2
das ist richtig geil wir wollen aber
noch ein bisschen sushi kommt wir
schicken jetzt mal ein bisschen wir
gehen mal in bettemburg aus welcher
kategorie hast du eigentlich auf ins
haus kommen dann darfst du dir nochmal
eine gänsehaut hier ein drehen sagt mir
eine zeit zwischen 1 und 14 uhr wird
weißt du was ist so lasse
geräusche dax mit sohn mario angehört
und so richtig lecker glaub ich finde
bei so viel muss man sich schon einmal
können wir gehen noch einmal in die
kategorie und bestellen da auf jeden
fall sagt wir eine zeit zwischen 1 und
50 thunfischen mayonnaise marke klingt
auch nicht schlecht oder
also dann 40 euro bestellen wir sehen
uns bald wenn das essen angekommen ist
das hat so bobby war so das ist so weit
dass es angekommen gefühl plötzlich euro
naja guck dir mal rein
meine taktik ich glaube das wird
wirklich mit love letter für sein
inneres probierte es erzeugt oder im
salat
cage ist so geil leute ich glaube es hat
noch niemand
und hier die miso suppe und das mit kuba
min ianu das natürlich das freut mich
jemand dann vergisst man automatisch
dass man 40 euro war doch und hier ist
das verschiebt sich euro muss ich sagen
das echt schon weniger der film jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen drüber damit ihr
das auch aus dieser perspektive mehr
sehen können
ach das ist dieses reich papier was wir
hatten dann haben wir
und da verträgt sich wenigstens noch mit
einer saturn und ich bin auch nicht so
super vielen ecken aktuell noch nie
probiert sehen der kann ja einmal so
wird wieder so normal zu essen in china
dann probier mal also misosuppe habe ich
noch nicht super häufig gegessen aber
immer wenn es gestern fand ich es nicht
vorlag
es hat irgendwie so hühnerbrühe wissen
alle die jetzt genau wissen was wieso
bedeutet wahrscheinlich jetzt weil ich
sage das mit einer hühnerbrühe probieren
sie auch mal
eigentlich ist der kind hier salat ich
wünsche euch immer ein bisschen anders
ich möchte einfach ein bisschen anders
von restaurant zu restaurant
ich bin ja das ist so toll dass die
vereine auch wieso hat mich vielleicht
gibt es auch für ballack aber eigentlich
sollte ist so richtig knackig und so
sein wie ich es gerade ein bisschen
komisch wie gesagt mein trainer
die kommen jetzt nämlich langsam wieder
das fühlt sich komisch an wenn ich höre
meine mutter wirklich übertrieben ist
kimchi immer schafft nein
ich hätte das ist so ein sucht schafe
gebe werfen immer alles was hörst du dem
team zu geben 0 bis 10
ich kenne hat anderes kind hier und
deswegen ist es für mich eine 4
tatsächlich war die suppe kann ich davor
nicht nur schmeckt habt wenn ich auch
wieder kimchi ist für mich eine
siebeneinhalb wettkämpfe nicht am 5
vom dinger richtigkeit aber auch
bisschen verrückt als salat gegessen
wird dass man mir zuletzt lachs salat
ist das glaube ich nicht
[Musik]
grund sei mein gott das war richtig
lecker schmeckt also das merkt auch dass
bei einem kran das schmeckt echt top das
schmeckt sehr sehr sehr nahe
das für mich nur 910 ich ja richtig
lecker welches war das jetzt machen
neben kasami die schmecken sehr genau
richtig da wartet immer noch was das
warme semmeln stellen können wir mit
sicherheit weiter aber probieren wir die
futuristische salad marke so mag die
rolle mit gekochten fisch schmecken
einfach standard oder du sagst du das so
eigentlich nur aus den inside out diese
klassischen wohl so aus wie sesam ist
das und sind so lecker ist es einfach so
mal so ein geiles avocado ist nur
neunter
da kann man auch mal ne harte arbeit
haben so schrieb todt ja gerade durch
die auch schon bei der arbeit wieder
sorgen ja auch das skript voll mit dem
weiß papieren das habe ich tatsächlich
so noch nie gesehen habt ihr aus
klebrigen store soll man das also besser
das ist gut weil essen kann man schon
mal nicht so läuft ihr habe ich echt
auch noch
raich kommt hier ist also voll der
heimauftakt ob man alles schaffen dann
weniger ist dadurch der frischkäse passt
richtig gut dazu nicht echt gutes so
alles wirklich gutes und leckeres muss
ich sagen haben wir echt glück gehabt
weil der gesetzgeber mit lara bestellt
haben besonders billig war scheiße wer
weiß wir haben ja noch ein special was
wir nach testen müssen in filmen
flambierte rolle
wir haben nicht am meisten gespannt da
fehlt mir auch mal so glaube ich damit
das perfekt wäre weil man so liebe ich
auch hin zu schieben er fällt zurück
richtig lecker aber muss ich auch vor
schluss elf euro ne hammer ist hält so
in sich
klar das ist so noch sechs mal musste er
dann aber auch diese soße obendrauf ja
und zehn von zwingend für mich mich auch
wir haben richtig glück leiter wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder danke
dafür dass ihr zugesehen hat mir richtig
geiles essen gegessen haben und mich
damit unterstützt perfekt lasst ihn wie
einen daumen hoch da abonniert den kanal
day hat letztens einfach einem video
gesagt dass er schneller halt nicht die
million haben will dass die leute ihn
abonnieren sollen deshalb abonniert mich
weil ich musste viel ihrer macht